some people say we not we need to fight
as dirty as the left or we're gonna lose
I don't agree with that we not to fight
as dirty but we have to fight as
aggressively and as relentlessly so here
we are on the Sunday special with David
Limbaugh author of Jesus is risen which
if true is bad news for me we'll get to
all that in just a second but first
let's talk about your time in the grave
you know occupying that basement condo
life insurance is a deeply unfun topic
most people don't like thinking about
dying because it's depressing they
actually don't like thinking about life
insurance either but having life
insurance feels great cuz if you're
gonna plotz you may as well not leave
your family bereft and getting that
peace of mind doesn't need to be
complicated policy genius is the easy
way to get life insurance in minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers to
find the coverage you need at a price
you can afford from there you can apply
online and the unbiased advisors at
policy genius will handle all the red
tape for you they'll leave you free to
do the things you actually enjoy like
you know not dying and policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
whether you're shopping for disability
insurance to protect your income or
homeowners insurance or auto insurance
they can help you get covered fast if
you've been intimidated or frustrated by
insurance in the past give policy genius
a try
just go to policy genius com to get your
quotes and apply in minutes you can do
the whole thing on your phone right now
in fact you probably should just hit
pause go to policy genius com get that
life insurance right now there's no
reason for you to die and leave your
family without any money at all go
through the responsible thing policy
genius the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance
well David Limbaugh thank you for coming
I really appreciate it thanks for having
me so for folks who don't know and this
means nobody knows because I haven't
told the story before the way that I got
started in political commentary was at
least partially due to David Limbaugh
who I met for the first time in person
today so we have been talking and
corresponding for legitimately seventeen
years and this is the first time we've
ever met in person actually so the way
that this started is I was writing a
column for the UCLA paper I applied to
creators syndicate which was your
syndicator for your column and I applied
cold and they picked me up and then I
had to get blurbs for the column so we
could send it off to various newspapers
and I emailed you out of the blue just
some random kid I was like can you give
me a blurb for my column you kindly said
sure and then you said and also if you
decide to write a book on college
campuses then I would be happy to be the
agent for it and I thought
okay well then I should probably go
ahead and do that and then I wrote
brainwashed yeah so we have been friends
for 17 years now yeah and it's pretty
amazing it took us this long to actually
meet in person yes I don't mean to put
you on the spot but tell us the story of
how we met that's a more specific than I
remember but that's exactly right and I
don't remember actually engaging in
solicitation for your legal business but
i but i but i did I did want to
encourage you to write an amazing
prodigy and and what has always amazed
me too about you is that you didn't take
off in an explosive way until maybe what
the last year or two five years maybe
last five five five years yeah and maybe
the Piers Morgan thing was the kind of
exactly yeah that's how fast time goes
but I've always haven't I always told
you that it's going to happen many times
many times and so it's gratifying I
loved and I don't take any credit for it
at all but I just love having been
present as this thing well you should
take some credit for because David was
one of the people who when I felt like
crying because I wasn't actually
progressing at the speed at which I was
hoping to David with you were always one
of the people who is telling me that
stick with it everything's gonna be okay
people will eventually come around yeah
and our mutual friend Ann Coulter wanted
to get you on the Supreme Court I had a
different path for you okay so let's
talk about ways that the church and
synagogue have that screwed up because
you look at religious observationally
country it's been markedly declining
since the 1950s the number of people who
are affiliated with an official religion
is is much lower now than it used to be
people say that they are spiritual but
not religious which is the most empty
phrase that I could possibly think of
absolutely it's like you get to you get
to say that you believe in God without
actually having to do anything about it
but it seems to me that there are three
problems three various approaches that
have been taken all have which have have
the problems approach number one is the
approach that you mentioned which is the
let's have pizza and a guitar and come
to church for the pizza and the guitar
and we won't talk politics at all we
will never threaten anything that you
think about life this seems to me the
direction in which a lot of churches
have gone thinking this is gonna draw in
young people young people don't want
that young people want eternal values
they want to know why they're here and
not in a movie right now they want to
know what it is that may
Church special what it is about our 3000
year history and Judaism in 2,000 year
history and Christianity that makes it
worthwhile to give up your Sunday
morning when you could be out playing
video games do you think that you know
the churches are doing a good enough job
of leaving behind that sort of soft
approach because I just I think that too
many of them are falling into this in an
attempt to fill the pews in short order
without actually getting to the root of
the matter yeah and I agree and it
worries me that you for example a pastor
a preacher has got to be willing to talk
about sin in the pulp from the pulpit if
he's afraid to turn people off then he's
doing a disservice now I don't think I
don't want pastors to inject politics
overtly I want them to advocate values
that are consistent with with the Bible
and that may be consistent with
conservative political values but not do
it in a political or partisan way and I
don't mean to do it
furtively I just mean preach the Bible
and preach Christian values but some of
them are afraid and they stay away from
these issues
I visited one church where the pastor
said right after Trump won we're gonna
pray for the people who here who weren't
in favor of Trump and I was so turned
off by that because what about did they
ever say that about Obama and I here's
the thing
I don't want pastors to be political
conservatives or political liberals I
wanted them to leave leave all of that
out and just preach the gospel preach
the Bible but some of them are afraid to
do that and even if they do get people
in the door I think ultimately they're
not going to keep them in the way that
they want to keep them because they're
not going to fill them with what they
need so I think that so we agree on
problem number one problem number two is
something you mentioned a little bit
earlier which is a feeling that you get
from a lot of people who don't have a
lot of familiarity with church or maybe
they do with the wrong churches when
they're when they're young this feeling
of incipient theocracy that you know the
folks you think Mike Pence is gonna
reinstitute The Handmaid's Tale because
he's a religious person and they think
back to their youth when they had a
priest or a pastor or a rabbi who used
to feel very oppressive I think it's
for you know religious communities to
point out look we're here to help guide
you and provide you the social fabric so
that you can do the right thing but
we're not interested in grabbing the
reins of government then cramming down
our version of life on you other than
protecting life liberty and property
that's exactly right and you while you
can look at the world history and say
well they did that there was we did
dabble a lot in theocracy and
intermixing Church state in that sense
but I think our framers were very clear
they wanted to prohibit the
establishment of a National Church and
the reason they wanted to do that is
because they knew that if you have one
church that's mandated then you don't
have religious liberty they wanted
religious liberty for everyone and I
mean you can argue about whether it's
ultimately about Christians and all
denominations being for whatever but I
don't care the print the spirit of it is
the same I don't as a Christian I don't
want to muzzle anyone I want the freedom
of religion and speech and Association
to be robust and that's one thing i
one-tailed tell-tale sign of the
difference between libs and
conservatives liberals are censors
liberals suppress Liberty Liberty
liberals are intolerant conservatives
and Christians are tolerant we have
nothing to fear from the marketplace of
ideas we just don't want people to keep
us from saying what we want to say such
as we're seeing now in the social media
but I'm on record on this I'm against
theocracy afirma it's the worst thing
you could ever do that's we're not
supposed to do that now I think the the
Jews were supposed to do that in the Old
Testament they wanted God wanted to be
their King directly they demanded a king
and he ultimately gave it to them but I
think you would probably agree with that
history maybe you would I mean fact I'd
be interested if you didn't but
Christians for sure and Jews today we
don't want theocracy do we nobody well I
mean even even in the Old Testament God
is is really dicey about kingship and
monarchy yeah I mean Samuel is really
not happy with the concept of of the
Jews wanting a king that's right right
so he has to be a much more direct
relationship between people and God
without this sort of intermediary
cramming things down yes from from the
top it supposed to be a relationship
between God and his children as opposed
to somebody who's actually the
enforcement
Gizem for for God from the from the top
that's a point so even that theocracy
was not what we think of theocracy today
right and even in that theocracy existed
in a different setting at a different
time obviously yes there there there are
many rabbinic responses to specifically
this issue because Jews have never been
in control of land for a couple of
thousand years up until 1947 1948 again
so then there's the third issue with
with church and and synagogue and that
is I think the most troublesome one for
a lot of conservatives and Republicans
and it gets into some pretty dicey
political territory which is of course
what makes this fun so that is there I
see it a lot among young people which is
the feeling that okay so you don't want
theocracy and you have values that
you're preaching what are you willing to
say about politicians who are doing good
stuff for you but may not share your
values and this obviously I'm referring
to President Trump yeah there's a lot of
controversy over how the event Jellicle
community has treated President Trump
with some people saying that the
evangelical community has acted
unfaithfully in a certain sense by
green-lighting his bad behavior other
people saying well you have to back him
I mean the opposition is legitimately
anti-life I mean not not pro-choice but
affirmatively celebrating yeah abortion
so how do you separate out the various
strands of how Trump should be treated
by the Christians if they want to reach
out particularly an intellectually
honest way to young people I think that
obviously it's it was a dilemma going in
and for me when I didn't support him
during the primaries and I there are a
lot of things about him I didn't like as
you well know I see Trump as kind of the
general in a in a culture war and in a
war for our salvation of the country
secular salvation I don't mean literally
I see the left is so crazy and and in so
antithetical to our views and what we
our vision of America that I applaud
Trump fighting now I I don't like all
the things he does obviously and I don't
want to lose my credibility or
intellectual honesty by defending things
that he does that I don't think are
right but since he's been in office as
opposed to
before I don't see him misbehaving that
my intern doesn't know sexual dallisa's
none of that kind of thing
he hasn't been accused of any of those
kinds of things everything that's come
up is about what has occurred prior to
being in office I think Trump one of the
reasons I was for cruising and and not
for Trump originally I didn't believe he
was a conservative and I think I was
rational and believing that but he
looked at his past I don't believe I'm
selling out by now saying I'm supporting
the fact the welcome fact that he has
changed and at least he's changed in
terms of his policies what we
anticipated and what he's doing he's
governing for the most part as a
conservative and that's gratifying to me
his tweets yeah I don't like the tone of
some of them obviously and you've
mentioned something I don't won't even
say but I do like the fact that he's
fighting see I think one of the reasons
we have this problem Trump is a symptom
of to me we have a perception that the
Republican Party wasn't fighting they
were squishes that they wouldn't ever
fight Obama went on budget battles that
they're always catering every time
there's a compromise between Republicans
and Democrats the the ball of socialism
is marched a little bit incrementally
down the field you never see it go the
other way when there's a compromise so
only when we win and we force it down
their throats I mean not force it but we
do it democratically they force it down
our throats I eat with Obamacare so I I
don't I I see Trump as governing
conservatively and I that some of the
things he says oh let me say this
I know that you and III here I watch and
listen your podcast lot I agree with you
99% of the time I think we have a
different perception though about Trump
and this is what bothers you about never
tremors they think we're sellouts I
haven't sold out I I have five kids I
have nothing to say I I love America as
much as I ever have I am not offended by
Trump's nationalism I don't see code in
Trump's nationalism to walk white
supremacy or are all right or any of
that I quote Trump and code don't mix
Trump is whatever he says is what he
says and and so I don't see any
these sinister motives that Trump has he
may say things that aren't true but but
I don't take him that seriously so as
before when I some of the things he did
I was just appalled
now I kind of laugh when I see these
videos of him in the wrestling thing now
I look back at him accusing Ted Cruz's
dad of saying I just laugh at that
because I don't it's so absurd and I
don't even take him seriously it was
dirty pool at the time don't get me
wrong
but I don't I just don't take see Trump
is some sinister guy I think he's really
working for the good of America I mean I
really have all the things he believes
I've really believed he loves America
and and I don't see a lot of evylyn and
I think as a Christian I have a duty to
support him because he's the guy that's
standing in the way of his standing
athwart the advance of leftism okay so I
want to ask you in a second about the
response to that and this is coming from
somebody who said I'm much more likely
now to support him than I was on 2016
but first I want to talk to you about
your second Amendment rights gun lovers
listen up did you enter to win your
brand-new gun from the US CCI yet if not
what are you waiting for
you're about to miss the deadline that's
wrong with you the gun today giveaway
ends very soon you could get up to 24
chances to win your gun daily but only
if you act right now it could be 24
Kimber's 24 Glocks 24 SIG's even 24
ar-15s just tech safe to the number 8 7
2 2 2 and reveal which gun you could be
taking home today they want law-abiding
citizens to have weaponry with which to
protect themselves you could be one of
those people hurry
these free guns are not going to last
long and today's gun disappears at
midnight tonight the u.s. CCI wants to
get more guns into the hands of
responsibly armed Americans like you
they're here to help train and protect
the protectors so do not put this off
don't miss your chance because you could
win a new gun every single day all you
have to do is text safe sa-a-afe
to the number 8 7 2 2 2 and enter right
now and remember you only have until
midnight tonight to win today's gun just
text the word safe - eight seven - two -
before it's gone forever again safe text
it to 8 7 - 2 - text safe - 8 7 - 2 -
check it out.you SCC has a lot of
fantastic services you're going to want
to be involved with them no matter what
and you have a chance to win a free gun
so why not text safe - 8 7 - 2 - all
right so the response to that
particularly when you talk to young
people is that some of the language
that you're using to describe President
Trump is is pretty flattering so you say
that he's the general in the culture war
example or that he you think that he's
doing what's best for the country and
the the other way of saying it sort of
the other side of the coin is dudes kind
of a schmuck right which is like
personally he does not he doesn't have a
history of treating women well obviously
he's been very skeezy and his business
dealings he lies a lot he says a lot of
things that aren't true but he's a
perfectly serviceable and better than
serviceable vessel for a lot of my
political priorities and for that reason
alone since all the damage that he was
going to do has now been done right I
mean I was afraid that he was going to
course in the public culture even though
it's already course he's done that it's
over can't put that cat back in the bag
all right he's going to he's going to
say things that I don't like he's done
that not sure that can be undone he's
going to soul suck the Republican Party
and I think he hasn't really done that
to too much of an extent um but when you
say to young people particularly that he
is a you know the feeling that he's a
great leader or that he's or that he's a
good man or that he's not or that he's
even a decent fellow like I don't think
that he's a particularly decent fellow I
wouldn't want him as a business partner
I don't think that he's a good man I
wouldn't want him around my wife
unsupervised um but as a vehicle for my
for my political viewpoint which is a
reflection of my values I would
certainly prefer him in the White House
to to Hillary Clinton or any other
Democrat that they are willing to run at
this point or probably in the near
future so with that being the case you
know we're both coming at it from the
perspective of people who are going to
vote for Trump in 2020 but I do wonder
if it undercuts the the message of
people who are value centric to lead
with the like it's what extent even feel
the need to defend Trump as a human as
opposed to defending your vote for Trump
as a politician well it depends on the
the charge against him I just I think
the facts ought to speak for themselves
and on a case by case basis I do believe
that he has become more conservative
substantively I don't agree with that
and but let me tell you what my theory
why III don't think he was ever
ideological he did have strong beliefs
on on tariffs and and trade
Wars and that kind of thing and
immigration but he hung around New York
liberals and he thought there were nice
guys they were nice to him and he's very
much a product of who I mean he responds
to people personally if they like him
and all that and you can say that's a
negative and I understand but now he
sees the left for what they are and now
he sees who the good guys are and
including the Christians and I actually
think there's been a transformation I
don't know about a conversion I have no
idea what he where he is spiritually but
I think he's moved in the right
direction substantively and idealize but
even beyond how he's governing I think
he's become to see who the good guys are
in this existential struggle for America
I don't want to say that to young people
or anybody else that if he's doing
something wrong that it's right I don't
want to say that it is but I might give
him some slack on things that I don't
take him that seriously about so if he
says I want to wrestle somebody to the
floor or he he talks but I don't want
him to curse in public obviously but if
he's combative that doesn't bother me I
want him to be combative because that's
what we've missed and that's what that's
why the basis so that's why there's
rallying around him because they see I
really believe this that we that the
Conservatives thought the tea party
thought that we weren't that there were
no leaders standing up for our values
and our ideas I something that does
bother me I am probably as idealistic as
you are I consider myself a
constitutional conservative I was for
Ted Cruz because I saw him as the
vintage pure Constitution constitutional
conservative now I I know Trump isn't
that and he isn't the kind of guy that
gives me give me goosebumps about
someone who will read constitutional law
and all that and I didn't agree with
these people who I argued with during
the primaries that we need somebody
who's going to come in and break
everything to fix it because I believe
what we needed to do was return to our
principles our constitutional principles
but since he's been in office I've had a
rethinking even of that I mean I've come
to believe and it may be rationalization
I don't know
I've come to believe that we did need
somebody to really shake things up
because I see if Ted Cruz had come in
and I still love Ted and I'm friends
with him I don't know that the country
would have allowed him to do what Trump
has done Trump is so unorthodox if
whether you give him credit for it just
say that his his nature is being so
unorthodox as result it is some things
really happening I didn't I don't agree
with the the people who now analyze I
think they got it right for the wrong
reasons but I think in retrospect they
were right that we needed to have things
just broken not our system and and
you're gonna say what and not you but I
say to myself then how do we restore
these this the purity of our system and
the constitutional constitutionality and
all that stuff well I think we can look
to him as honoring the Constitution I
don't agree with the people who say he's
so authoritative
he likes Putin because Putin liked him
he likes he might admire tough guys but
he's not he's not doing anything that's
a threat in fact the only thing he
really did the the only executive order
that he ever did that I thought was
blatantly unconstitutional was when he
backed when he when he reversed himself
at the at the pressure of liberals on
the border thing now there are probably
other examples I don't fear him I don't
see that he wants to do any of that and
when he makes these statements I wish I
could be king Obama said that stuff and
meant it I don't think Trump means it so
let's go back to this topic about
President Trump shaking things up so my
view of President Trump shaking things
up is I can name maybe one place where I
think that no other Republican would
have done it and that is moving the
embassy to Jerusalem I think no other
Republican does that I think that he is
so out of the box and so on Orthodox a
thinker that he thought okay there's no
reason for this let's just do it it's
obvious that we should do it let's do it
I think even Ted Cruz would have had
difficulty doing it but in terms of
shaking things up I think Ted Cruz
probably gets the tax cut I think the
Ted Cruz probably gets whatever reversal
of Obamacare happened because it's just
whatever Republican votes are there I
think he probably appoints the same
justices may be better justices in the
case of Kavanagh we'll have to see how
care now goes so where do you think that
the shaking things up has has really
benefited the country and the
conservative movement when I say I I
don't I don't want to make the same that
that he could have done it better than
Cruz in the sense of I don't mean he
would have advocated better I just think
because of his personality in his
charisma he's able to get things done
that Ted might not Ted they they had so
demonized Cruz that they I think they
would have neutered him politically I
don't think he would have backed down
one bit I just don't think he would have
and I don't want to say he might he's
the one exception I don't want to say
anything negative about him because I
don't regret my support for Rights but I
just think in the end Trump because of
his unorthodoxy might have even on
Kavanagh he defends Kavanagh he says
right he is somebody more circumspect
may say we got a lot wait for the
evidence to come in and Trump waited but
then he finally said this woman is not
telling the truth those kind of things
Trump has more courage for whatever
reason it may you may attribute it to
the wrong things but he's just he's just
a street fighter fighter he's a brawler
and I know of any problem that in fact
some people say we not we need to fight
as dirty as the left or we're gonna lose
I don't agree with that we don't have to
fight as dirty but we have to fight as
aggressively and as relentlessly as they
do so well how do you think this plays
out in 2020 so I'm I will admit that I
was a skeptic leading up to 2016
obviously because the data suggested
skepticism Trump wins the shocked
victory my theory is that no one showed
up to vote for Hillary Clinton my
evidence for that is that he won fewer
votes in Wisconsin than Mitt Romney did
Trump did and won the State Hillary
Clinton lost the stake has no one likes
Hillary in the dirty little secret in
2016 is that it was not in fact a
referendum on President Trump it was a
referendum on the worst candidate in the
history of the Republic who everyone
despised including Democrats voted for
Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders in the
primaries so 2018 comes around and we
get shellac I mean we look it looks now
like we're gonna lose 40 seats when all
is said and done in the house which is a
shellacking we are only able to with
gain two seats in the Senate in a cycle
where there are ten Democratic seats
that were up for reelection what is your
perspective going into 2020 are you
optimistic that Trump is able to win
reelection
if so why I'm not optimistic but I'm not
pessimistic I thought we were gonna make
it closer in the house but I don't think
we got shellacked in historical from a
historical perspective but we lost way
worse than we wanted to know and that
looked like we were going to before I do
think that Trump has some
thing that other people didn't have that
attributed that contributed to his
victory he can really rally his base and
and like nobody I've ever seen he came
to cape girardeau for the the Holly
rally and you can't believe the the way
he energizes people and he gives a good
stump speech and gets people motivated
now and we've talked about whether not
we've talked about but I've been reading
the Trump can do this with his base but
he has to go beyond his base
I think Newt just says and and nobody
can deny Newt Gingrich his brilliance
and especially as a strategist if he if
he really gets the base Multi hyper
expanded we will win anyway I don't I
don't believe that but but I believe
again that what the left will probably
do in the next two years will reveal
them more and more for how unreasonable
they are and how extreme they are they
might get smart and not be extreme but
we Trump we have to have a good economy
remember Trump wasn't running he wasn't
he wasn't running in this election but
these elections weren't nationalized
and in the presidential election will be
obviously by definition and they're all
voting for one candidate versus the
other as opposed to 450 435 different
districts I think that he has a very
good chance of winning but it depends on
I saw Steve dace write a column the
other day saying I'll tell you right now
whether Trump's gonna win it's whether
the Democrats put up somebody likable if
they put up somebody that's not likable
he'll win if it's like if the person is
likable he won't now that kind of goes
with your 2016 theory that Hillary
wasn't and all that but I don't think
it's that simple Steve days very smart
guy but I I think that the economy is
going to make a big difference and who
the Democrats put up obviously but I
don't think likability is all there is
to it these people who said who
purported to know what was going to
happen a year out to mean that's just
folly you can't things can change
overnight and we've seen it literally
change overnight
I think we've got to do much better
messaging and going forward and Trump
has I wish there
was away that Trump you could have a
good Trump without the bad right when I
say the bad Trump I'm talking about the
shooting himself in the foot uncertain
of his tweets and but but I like a lot
of his tweets he could like I said he
could be combative without being
personal I mean he could even be
personal as long as he isn't rude and
insulting in ways that he shouldn't
write I mean I've said I've suggested
that we actually create a fake Twitter
app and we put it on his phone and then
we can actually squeeze tweets he
actually tweets it out and get some fake
feedback he thinks that it's real
feedback and he goes around the rest of
the aisle happy yeah and it never sees
the light of day outside of the White
House yeah something like that because
obviously I agree there are a lot of
great benefits to a guy with as much
charisma as much magnetism I mean the
guy can bring a spotlight like nobody in
the history of American politics clearly
and having all of that without the the
downsides of saying whatever fails to be
caught between his brain mouth filter
would would definitely be a good thing
well I don't have as jaded of you as you
do have him I probably did during the
primaries I don't see him as a person
that that is just all negative and all I
see if he you got to remember something
else they have attacked him so much and
yes he's in one sense thin-skinned you
know whatever you want to call it but
he's legitimately responding to the to a
relentless assault personal assault and
so he's defending himself and he's got a
forum to do it sometimes I think he goes
overboard is with the Adam Schiff thing
that kind of thing you know ship
deserves ridiculed but but he doesn't
need to gratuitously put that in like a
lot of people on Twitter you know the
urge to be rude and funny and then you
wake up the next day I wish I hadn't
done it and what I try to do on Twitter
is to live a good example and try to be
nice to be believing people that are
mean to me but I'm biting my tongue the
whole much nicer on Twitter than I am I
know but but I don't want to be my
instinct is to go and for blood and eye
I can see Trump he's a brawler and he
just he doesn't but I don't see him as
some sinister guy I see him as really
wanting to help the country yeah I gets
too personal and stuff but I just with
young people we I think young people
have got to be we've got to educate
young people to what we face that how
they're going to lose
their liberties and everything that was
built for them if the left continues to
win well so then this seems like a
question as to what the future of the
Democratic Party you would hope to see
looks like because in the one sense it
sounds like you would like to the
Democratic Party reveal their full scale
radicalism for everybody so that way we
have a better chance of victory in 2020
at the same time if that full scale
radicalism wins out then you have a
full-scale radical Democratic Party in
charge of the government so which
direction would you like to see the
Democratic Party take well they're
impotent now though that all they can do
is obstruct all they have is the house
and so no I do not I don't subscribe to
this view let them in charge so they can
show just how bad they are and destroy
the country I don't think we have many
years left I don't think we have many
chances that's out at me but if you if
you had your druthers would they run it
in 2020 a more moderate candidate who
appeals to the Rust Belt because you
want to viable parties or would you
prefer they run somebody completely
radical so that the country can see and
then we risk whether that person wins or
not well that would be a calculation if
I thought the person could win I
wouldn't want them to run but I don't
believe there's many almost any such
thing as a moderate Democrat anymore
they build people like that Sherrod and
all that I don't believe it all these
Democrats vote and enable the radicalism
that we see in the country so I think
that that's one of the reasons I think
the things that separate never trampers
by the way I don't consider you never
try never I'm not never yeah right yeah
like I was during the election but it to
me just so folks folks understands the
the sort of breakdown of what never
Trump is never Trump was a movement that
existed it wasn't really even a movement
it was more like a self-definition
in 2016 will you vote for Trump in
general will you not vote for Trump in a
general I did not vote for Trump in the
general so I was a never Trump er but
after the election happened there's
nothing to vote for anymore now he's the
president so the question becomes is he
good or is he bad and so I've declared
myself a sometimes Trump or was good
also if you if you had a if you had had
a crystal ball and you would govern like
this and you yeah then you would have
voted for him yes okay yeah yeah the
difference our calculation is I think I
think that Hillary was so bad and I
think we're closer to the precipice to
losing this country I don't know about
you but I think I see Tom Nichols
been friendly with him on Twitter but he
advocated voting for all Democrat max
boot
these people are unhinged I can't
understand how you could be a
conservative and advocate because they
think that that if you do that you'll
ultimately bring the conservative part
of the Republican Party back to its
senses I don't think we have the time
and I think we're already back to our
senses I don't I don't think we've sold
our soul I think we are in a desperate
war with the left to preserve America
and Trump's the guy leading the charge
right now and and he's just the one
doing it and we're supporting him for
that reason but I don't think they see
the gravity of the threat the
existential nature of the threat and the
immediacy the urgency of it to the
extent that I do I may be wrong but I
don't see that we have a lot of time
left okay so I want to ask in a second
about your book Jesus's words in which
as I say contrasts sharply with the
Jewish version of this book yeah nope
well I do want to talk about your
religious writing we'll get to that in
just a second but first when the
founders crafted the Constitution the
first thing they did was make sacred the
rights of the individual to share ideas
with alimentation by the government the
second right they enumerated was the
right of the population to protect that
speech and their own persons with force
you know how strongly I believe in these
principles I'm a gun owner owning a
rifle is an awesome responsibility
building rifles is no different Bravo
company manufacturing BCM was started in
a garage by a marine vet more than two
decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they are a private citizen or a
professional vcm is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer and
manufacture life-saving equipment then
they assume that every rifle that leaves
their shop will be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen or a law enforcement officer or
a soldier overseas every component of a
BCM rifle is hand assembled and tested
by Americans to a life-saving standard
to learn more about bravo company
manufacturing head on over to bravo
company MFG comm where you can discover
more about their product special offers
upcoming news that's Bravo Company MFG
comm if you need more convincing go
check them out at youtube.com slash
Bravo Company you se you can find out
all about BCM and the awesome people who
make their products youtube.com / Bravo
company USA okay first let's start with
your political writing because you were
well-known for your political writing
you'd written a bunch of New York Times
bestsellers on politics before
you ever started writing about religion
what got you into writing politically in
the first place Regnery publishing asked
me to write my first book on the clinton
reno justice department they thought i
had a column and i'm a lawyer and so i
agreed to do it having no idea what i
was doing and i started doing it i mean
i started writing the book and studying
to write the book researching and more I
research the more I floundered realizing
what's this gonna buy the more I read
about it the less I think I know I don't
know how to organize this and and and
not to bring up Coulter again but she
told me she was an author for regularly
at the time and she said just start
writing and all of a sudden you're
you'll you'll your organization will be
a byproduct of that and I really think
that was simple but profound advice once
you start writing you necessarily become
organized because you have to focus on
what you're writing about so what was
your family like growing up because
obviously there's you you're obviously
very political your brother is rush
limbaugh yeah yeah your your father was
a judge correct my dad is a lawyer my
grandfather was a lawyer my uncle was a
judge so I I oh we grew up as
Republicans my dad was a Goldwater
conservative very smart politically he
would hold court in our house a lot of
times our friends would go out and look
for girls and all that but but other
people's friends our friends would come
to our house and listen to my dad
scientific eight he was kind of Russia's
predecessor but he just did it in the
living room and so it was it like to
grow up in that house mean people always
say must've been fascinating around the
dinner table and the truth is no we just
listen to my dad we didn't we've never
talked but we did absorb it and in fact
when rush first got into radio I mean he
always wanted to be a radio guy and that
didn't surprise me but when he started
when he started talking about politics I
couldn't believe how insightful he was
now knowledgeably was because he didn't
talk about it that was wheat he moved
away when he was 18 or 19 and we we got
closer the older we got but he left and
once I first saw him make a speech at
the Lions Club when I came to visit him
in Sacramento and he had a radio show
out here which
his forerunner to his national show oh
man he's like my date he knows all this
stuff I can't believe how good he is I'm
knowledgeable so but at our house it was
mainly we listened and we absorbed so
how did you move from political writing
into religious writing because you've
written several books on the Gospels in
the New Testament and the historicity of
Jesus how did you move into in sort of
the religious space after writing all
these New York Times bestsellers on
politics well the first book I tried was
about the Old Testament I and this is I
think we've talked about this before but
one of the things that convinced me of
Christ deity is the Messianic prophecies
obviously Judaism doesn't accept those
we laughingly discussed that before but
that kind of tipped me over the edge
when I looked at the Messianic
prophecies I've always been a doubter I
believed in God but I didn't believe in
the God of the Bible but it wasn't that
I'd ever investigated the God of the
Bible
I just negligently and recklessly
rejected him without ever studying it
and so once I began studying it and
realized or I came to the conclusion
that the Bible is the Word of God it
kind of hit me like an epiphany and I
wanted to inhale everything I could
about it and so I started writing a book
about the Old Testament the first three
books and I submitted that to a
Christian agent and he said it's a
little highfalutin for a person with no
credentials and it's not informal enough
for the other so basically buzz off and
so this was when I was in my 30s and I
was a little bit discouraged but so I
thought okay I'm but I still I continued
to study for the next 20 years I've
continued to study pretty intensely
Christianity and theology and it was
only after and I by the way at that
point I had no platform
I had no columns written no books and
done nothing and along these lines other
than practice law and so after five
political books and a syndicated column
for 15 however many years it was I
decided to revisit this I still didn't
know if I had the credentials I mean I
knew I didn't because I'm not a pastor
and all that but I felt like there are
so many people that are not
that don't hear the message of
theologians and pastors they don't they
don't have access to some of the great
writings that I do and they they don't
read apologetics I thought well I can
bridge this gap between for the
laypeople and I can introduce them to
all this research and all the things
that finally convinced me so I wrote the
first book Jesus on trial as a
chronological history of my faith
journey and also as a book on
apologetics and then I continued after
that into the Emmaus code and then the
last book before this one was a true
Jesus which is about the Gospels where I
just consolidated all four Gospels into
one running narrative and had commentary
along with it this book jesus is risen
follows the Gospels it's the book of
Acts was of the history of the early
church and six of the Apostle Paul's 13
epistles so it's it's really not a
history of the church it's a history of
the church insofar as it tracks the
Bible what this book does is track those
books every verse in the Bible either
stated or paraphrase and then a
commentary with some of the great
Christian thinkers and then my own
insights so where do you think the the
real gap since you've obviously you're
very familiar with the Old Testament and
the New Testament where do you see that
the real difference is philosophically
coming in between Old Testament
religions of Judaism and and the New
Testament because there seem to be a
couple of different views about this one
is that Jesus radically shifts kind of
the narrative of the Old Testament in a
different direction what is that he
comes to complete the law and so it's
more of a newer and more complete gloss
on the Old Testament but where do you
see that the difference is between old
and new testaments okay I believe that
the Christian theology believes and I
believe that the New Covenant supersedes
the Old Covenant but the New Testament
doesn't supersede the Old Testament it
is the second part of a two-part story
of God's salvation history and you know
I I'm amused by all these secular
critics who say Jesus is all salt and
light and love and he never got mad and
never reprimanded anyone and what they
don't realize is if if Christian
theology is true the the Bible the God
we worship is triune and so Jesus was
with the father and the Holy Spirit at
the creation so of course he embraced
everything in the Old Testament and it
was intended to be and the Jews were the
chosen people are the chosen people of
course the the Christian view is that
they're the chosen people to bring the
gospel ultimately to the rest of the
world they anticipated a messiah who
would be a political deliverer or
military deliver and they according to
Christian theology not through their own
fault but miss apprehended what the Old
Testament scripture was saying what it
was really saying is he would Christ
would be a suffering servant and he
would die for his sins so when he died
not only did he not deliver a political
victory he was humiliated and didn't
even lift a finger to defend himself and
he died and even some of his disciples
at that point Peter denied him after he
died even after having lived with him
and seeing all his miracles it wasn't
until he they witnessed his bodily
resurrection that they were transformed
from cowards and skeptics to bold for
claimants of the gospel but I believe
that the Old Testament is absolutely
true absolutely the world Word of God
every bit inspired and that there is
total consistency now I as to whether
the the Mosaic law is still valid I mean
obviously the Apostle Paul talks about
Christians not having to be circumcised
and all that because it's about faith in
Jesus Christ it's not about works but
the Christian view is that it was never
about works and that salvation is
nothing to do with works because we
can't save ourselves we're all sinners
and so you have to this you have to put
aside your pride and put all your trust
or faith in Jesus to bridge that gap
between sinfulness and God's perfect
sinlessness so this is one of the
descriptions I'd heard between Judaism
and Christianity the Judaism is much
more acts based whereas Christianity is
much more faith based so one might say
okay if you're if you're a Christian
you're some people say why is why is in
Christ there's Liberty people say you
know you get rid of your change or
Christian and then other people say no
because you Christians are scolds you
you have to you
to a higher standard well in fact here's
the difference Christians believe that
we we do not have to follow the law as a
matter of following them in terms of
some strict requirement but that when
you're under the law of Christ the law
of Christ isn't really a law it's a
matter of love and obedience and you
even hold yourself to a higher standard
supposedly but you but we believe that
you can't hold yourself to I mean that
you can't fulfill the Ten Commandments
on your own strength it's impossible for
any sinful human being and we're all
sinners to live up to that standard God
can't allow sin in his presence so
there's got to be a way to cancel out
that sin and that's that's Jesus but but
we don't believe that I don't believe
that all these laws have been eradicated
the Mosaic law in fact all of them are
still enforced there's still God's
perfect laws we still live by those
precepts there's a debate about whether
we follow the Sabbath and all that and
that hasn't been reaffirmed some people
believe some people don't but basically
those law those were God's laws they
were perfect laws but the Christian view
is they couldn't deliver salvation they
were to demonstrate to people their
inadequacies so the law was given to
show people how they couldn't live
sinless lives and there and that would
draw them to Christ it's more complex
than that so in this view of
Christianity is it better to be a sinner
with faith or a saint without so you're
a person who fulfills as many you're a
good person you fulfill all 10
commandments better than most people but
you don't believe in Jesus
well what what does that mean in in the
Christian faith the Christian faith is
that salvation is only through Jesus now
when you say better I think there's a
lot better acting people that aren't
Christians a lot of non-christians are
better acting than I am so I'm not not
making that and I don't like this
judgemental stuff that some Christians
have and one of the things that turned
me off originally the Skjold
aspect but the theory is that when you
accept Christ and you're converted
you're justified and that upon that
moment you're you're freed from the
penalty of sin so for salvation purposes
when God looks at you he doesn't see you
he sees Christ sinlessness he can't see
you
Spurgeon one of the great British
pastors wrote about this God can't help
but when he looks upon you and you've
accepted Christ all he can see is his
son that's for salvation purposes but
also something happens when you accept
Christ and that is you're also freed
from the power of sin meaning the Holy
Spirit begins to indwell you and
empowers you to combat sin on a daily
basis doesn't mean that you will ever
overcome sin as a practical matter but
you will become holier you'll become
more christ-like more sanctified at the
more you avail yourself of the Holy
Spirit and so you will become a better
person in that sense in an active sense
but you'll never be sin free this this
side of eternity I want to ask about a
misapprehension that seems to be had by
a lot of folks particularly in the
Jewish community about the evangelical
Christian view of Israel the the
misperception seems to be the only
reason that evangelical Christians care
about the State of Israel and the Jews
generally is because the goal is to get
all the Jews back to Israel at which
point Jesus makes his reappearance the
the the rapture happens and everything
is great from then on in but if it
weren't for all that then Israel screw
up that obviously is inaccurate I am
particularly offended by that first
place Christ was a Jew Jesus was a Jew
that's indisputable I believe we have a
duty to love Jews and and not and
through we believe that Christians
derive their salvation through Judaism
and through Jews and it so it's open to
everyone by the way it's not just open
to Gentiles it's open to everyone I also
don't I reject this notion and I also
don't understand it and I know a lot of
Christians who feel this way this is a
little bit different but it's analogous
point they want Jesus to come back they
want him to return and they I can't wait
for Jesus coming I don't get that
because if you believe you're saved and
if you believe you're going to spend
eternity with God anyway what differs if
he doesn't make if he comes back and
exacts revenge on your on your enemies
or whatever I don't even understand that
but I'm
I believe that that Israel is the Jews
everlasting possession I believe in the
Abrahamic covenant I believe that it has
not been eradicated I don't agree with
the Covenant 'el theologians as opposed
to the dispensationalist or whatever who
believe that the church has been
substituted for Israel I believe Israel
is Israel that land is theirs forever
and when I think about the Jews
returning to Israel in 1947 1948 that
gives me goosebumps about the validity
of the Bible and God's superintendent's
and sovereignty that's just too
unbelievable that that happened that God
for God not to be behind it and I
believe that those who bless bless
Israel will be blessed those who curse
Israel will be cursed and but I don't
even have to I don't I don't might
allegiance to Israel and to Jews isn't
because I'm afraid I'll be smacked down
I believe it's just part of it I just I
have an affinity I'm not trying to to
patronize you but I've felt that way
since
and I think believing Jews feel that way
they can sense it the idea that we want
to usher in this end times and and
expedite the rapture I know there's some
Looney Tunes out there that have that
and some people I guess but I but I
don't know anybody in nobody that I
respect wants to do it for that reason
they want to do it because they're so
sick of how crazy the world has become
and that I can understand but not for
the sake of ushering again for any other
reason and not for utilitarian purposes
about the Jews that's pretty cynical and
it but I know I'm not saying you're
simcha there are a lot of mystery
Hendriks about all of this and I think
that it's really important to elucidate
that because when I say it people don't
believe it the same way they would from
someone who actually studies my stuff so
we've spent a lot of time talking about
sort of the divisions between
Christianity and Judaism but it seems to
me that right now in the United States
and more broadly the the grave division
is between judea's between believers in
the judeo-christian value system and
everybody else that they're there right
now they're a group of people who
believe that essentially the values of
the Bible are the correct values as
filtered down through thousands of years
of thought history and evidence and that
that is what has created Western
civilization and there's a whole other
group of people who believe that
judeo-christian civilization basically
stands in the way of progress and that
all of the hallmarks of judeo-christian
civilization have to be obliterated in
the name of of that progress and this
seems to me to mirror a lot the division
between right and left what do you make
of that generalized thesis totally agree
I I think that the judeo-christian
tradition is what has given rise to this
unique system that we have this unique
country the freest most prosperous most
benevolent nation in the history of the
world and if I had to I mean we could go
in and we could talk about how the
majority of the founding fathers were
strong practicing Christians there's
debate about that I mean some people
point to the high profile Ben Franklin
Thomas Jefferson who are arguably not
strong Christians they might have been
deus or whatever but the overwhelming
majority of them were Christian and they
believed in the Christian the
judeo-christian ethic and by the way
just so people don't think I'm
patronizing judeo-christian is not some
euphemism it's I considered Old
Testament New Testament as a peace and
so that's what we're talking about and
so I think you can look at our founding
and trace it and I also think that the
development of all these ideas you can
trace back to Christianity and and Jude
I mean Judy and Christianity okay so I
do have one final question to ask you
specifically I want to ask you to give
your elevator pitch for why people
should go back to church in accordance
with your book but if you want to hear
David's answer you have to be a daily
wire subscriber to subscribe go to daily
wire com click subscribe you can hear
the end of our conversation there well
David thank you so much for stopping by
and it is so cool that we finally get to
meet up in nearly 20 years thank you so
much thanks so much for coming in
[Music]
eventually row shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate producer
Mathis Glover edited by Alex Singaram
audio is mixed by Dylan case Heron
makeup is by Jess wah all Vera and title
graphics by Cynthia and gula the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018
[Music]